mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la député
il faut décrire la réalité telle qu'elle
est nous étions dans la situation nous
sommes encore de la situation vous
l'avez rappelé où il y avait 50 millions
de poussins qui étaient broyés chaque
année notamment pour les filières de
poules pondeuses et notamment pour les
œufs que vous consommez et que nous
consommez les uns les autres chaque
année et donc nous avons décidé
effectivement de prédécesseur Julien de
Normandie avait décidé de lancer un
grand plan d'abord pour trouver les
technologies qui permettent de faire le
beau sexage parce qu'elle n'était pas
forcément opérante au moment où ils ont
dans nos avions parlé c'était à l'époque
dans régalim et deuxièmement pour
trouver un modèle économique qui permet
quand même de prendre en compte les
coûts de cette filière effectivement
nous serons au rendez-vous le 1er
janvier 2023 puisque l'ensemble de la
filière des poules pondeuses sera bien
conserver par la fin du broyage pour
faire vos sexages et ça sera un nouveau
sexage classique qui sera fait par des
moyens technologiques que vous
connaissez donc c'est la fin du voyage
pour les poussins il reste effectivement
une dérogation sur un certain nombre de
filières c'est 10 à 12% 12% environ de
la filière globale vous pourriez saluer
quand même l'avancée qu'il y a la nôtre
qui est celle d'être à l'un des premiers
pays du monde avec l'Allemagne avec la
Suisse si j'ai bonne mémoire qui se
lance dans cette dans cette nécessité de
donc aux exigences de bien-être animal
nous allons continuer à travailler sur
ce qu'il reste de la filière qui ne peut
pas aujourd'hui par les technologies
répondent à la demande que nous
partageons tous et donc nous avons un
travail à faire et puis deuxième élément
de la réponse que je vais vous faire
faut qu'on travaille au niveau européen
on a besoin aussi dans ces filières de
ne pas se cacher derrière l'hypocrisie
qui ferait qu'on allait on aille faire
broyer dans d'autres pays pour récupérer
les produits ensuite parce que c'est
assez facile de le dire quand on laisse
faire le travail aux autres et donc nous
avons besoin d'avoir un dispositif
européen qui permettent de garantir que
l'ensemble du broyage de Poussin sera
désormais éliminé mais au 1er janvier
tous nos concitoyens dans les grandes
surfaces dans les épiceries ils
trouveront des œufs ou au détail ils
trouveront des œufs qui ne sont plus le
produit du voyage c'est bien ça
l'essentiel et vous devriez vous en
féliciter de même que féliciter la
filière de même que la grande
distribution qui s'est pleinement
mobilisée y compris financièrement aux
côtés de l'État nous avons mis 10
millions d'euros de notre côté côté état
pour faire en sorte qu'on avance sur le
sujet alors il suffit pas de Yaka faucon
madame la députée faut avancer c'est ce
que nous en
merci monsieur le ministre